the new payroll protection program has
processed more than 500 billion dollars
in loans to help small businesses
survive the coronavirus crisis President
Trump said last night that more stimulus
8 is likely to be approved but critics
say that the PPP isn't doing what it was
meant to do its loans will be forgiven
only if businesses spend 75 percent of
that money on their employees in just
eight weeks as ed O'Keefe reports many
business owners are not spending it
because so many people including their
workers are staying home on unemployment
I was getting almost $700 a week and if
I were to go back to work
I'd probably be lucky to get a minimum
of four hundred hairstylist Audrey
Boswell was laid off when her salon
closed due to the corona virus but after
her boss received money from the
paycheck protection program she was
asked to return to work honestly
in Arkansas salons have - I have not
actually been allowed to officially
reopen yet it's not like you want to be
unemployed no no I want to go back to
work but I want to go back to work when
it's safe and for me to refuse to go
back to work and then get kicked off
unemployment I mean it's it was just a
double-edged sword out-of-work Americans
like Audrey are facing some tricky math
state unemployment benefits range from a
maximum of two hundred thirty-five
dollars a week in Mississippi to just
over 450 in Arkansas - more than $800 in
Massachusetts when Congress passed the
cares act in March the bill is passed
Republicans criticized the decision to
tack on an extra $600 per week to
unemployment payments through the end of
July you're literally incentivizing
taking people out of the workforce it
means some workers are now making more
money without a job then with one if
you're a barista suddenly be on
unemployment is looking pretty good
Mary Ellen Lindemann runs coffee by
design in Portland Maine which received
more than $400,000 through PPP but the
program allows just eight weeks to meet
hiring targets if they want the loan
forgiven we were being told 48 full-time
people needed to come back and we had a
stay at home order in place
so how exactly were we going to get 42
people back when we can't open our
locations if you could tell members of
Congress how they might consider fixing
it going forward what would you tell
them we need more time you can't rebuild
companies in eight weeks and for those
who are not even allowed to be open
there's no way you can rebuild a
business when the state is telling you
you can't be open for business
Lorri Hamill who owns six fitness
centers in New England in Utah agrees
small companies are going to need more
time it's not like turning on a light
switch it's like pumping up a tire with
a bicycle pump a flat tire with a
bicycle pump so it's gonna be gradual so
we need three months to be able to get
back to full staffing in Maine PPP is
helping Lindemann bring some employees
back including Casias para who
sacrificed an extra $500 a week she
would have made from unemployment
insurance for the security of a job
prefer to have a secure job right now
looking for a job
there are proposals in the Senate to
give some of these businesses more time
for loan forgiveness and if the rules
don't change the business owners we
spoke to said that despite the
challenges they may not be able to spend
all the money they've been given Gail
boy yeah that's a problem but there's
something out of whack why should people
go back to work if they can make more
sitting at home collecting unemployment
Senator Graham has that right right that
is active no it's it's a big problem and
we sat there doing the math with these
folks and they're very concerned about
it yeah yeah all right thank you very
much and if you've been unemployed
during this pandemic we'd really like to
hear about your experience please email
us at coronavirus at CBS news.com